divide 63 y entre 75 y muy bien queremos
hacer una división de números complejos
pero también queremos que el resultado
sea un número complejo es decir que sea
de la forma un real más un imaginario o
sea un real por y vale bueno para hacer
esto déjame primero reescribir esta
expresión como una fracción el primer
término se hace el numerador 6 más 3
y el segundo término se hace el
denominador hasta ahorita no he hecho
nada nada demasiado complicado ahora
para realizar esta operación lo que
vamos a utilizar es una de las
herramientas que tenemos en los números
complejos que son los conjugados
complejos lo que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar esta expresión en el
numerador y el denominador por el
conjugado complejo de 7 menos 5 y déjame
escribirlo aquí a la derecha para ver a
qué me refiero
entonces en color rojo voy a poner el
conjugado el con juego simplemente es
cambiar el signo a la parte imaginaria
entonces sería multiplicar por 7-5 y 7-5
y y dividir
dividir entre 75 y esto no altera la
expresión porque cualquier cosa entre sí
misma es uno bueno a menos que esa cosa
sea 0 dividir entre 0 no está definido
nunca pero bueno en este caso no hay
problema podemos multiplicar y dividir
por esta expresión y no estamos
alterando nada pero la ventaja de esto
es que ahora podemos multiplicar arriba
y abajo y pues deshacernos o más bien
cambiar la parte imaginaria de aquí
abajo por algo que nada más es real
entonces vamos a ver que nos queda
entonces realizando la multiplicación
voy a poner aquí esta línea de numerador
y denominador entonces lleno arriba que
nos queda multiplicando pues para
multiplicar que multiplicar cada término
de este número complejo por cada término
de este número complejo lo puedes pensar
utilizando la ley distributiva o este
método que en inglés se conoce como foil
pero bueno ahorita lo vamos a hacer así
multiplicando cada uno con cada uno
simplemente es aplicar dos veces la ley
distributiva entonces qué nos queda nos
queda 6 por 7 es 42 42 luego tenemos que
hacer 6 por 5
6 x 5 es 30 entonces nos quedaría más 36
por 5 30 ok luego tenemos que hacer 3
por 7 bueno 3 y por 7 que nos quedaría
más 21 y finalmente hay que multiplicar
este 3 y con este 5 y perovic y con y
nos va a dar y cuadrada y 3 por 5 nos va
a dar 15 pero y cuadrado es menos uno
entonces nos quedaría menos menos 15
sale 3 por 5 15 y por iu y cuadrada pero
y cuadrada es menos 1 muy bien vamos al
denominador aquí abajo podríamos
utilizar este truco de diferencia de
cuadrados que vimos en en algún vídeo
anterior pero déjame hacer otra vez las
operaciones para que veamos de dónde
sale entonces aquí sería 7 por 7 49 7
por 7 49 estoy poniendo en color como
rosa mexicano luego 7 por 5 y es más 35
y más 35 y ahora va menos 5 y con 7 que
sería menos 35
y finalmente es menos 5 y por más 5 y
aquí hay que tener cuidado con los
signos y x y es cuadrada que es menos 1
luego menos por más es menos pero con s
menos 1 de la y se hace más entonces
aquí nos quedaría más 5 por 5 que es 25
25 muy bien si te das cuenta eso es lo
mismo que 7 al cuadrado más 5 al
cuadrado que es el patrón que platicamos
en vídeos anteriores pero bueno vamos a
ver qué nos queda aquí abajo esto se
cancela con esto entonces en el
denominador en el denominador nos queda
49 más 25 que es 74 74 y en el numerador
pues tenemos que juntar partes reales
con reales e imaginarias con imaginarias
entonces las partes reales son este 42 y
éste 42 y este menos 15 42 menos 15 es
27 lo pongo aquí 27 y luego tenemos que
sumar las partes imaginarias que es 30
con 21
51 sería esta con esta nos queda más 51
y y bueno finalmente tenemos que
escribir esto de la forma más vil o sea
un real más bueno imaginario y
simplemente vamos a distribuir este 74
porque dividir entre 74 es lo mismo que
multiplicar por 1 entre 74 entonces pues
podemos pensar que es este entre este
más este entre este bueno lo voy a hacer
para para que quede claro entonces
distribuimos esta división entre 74 y
entre estos dos números nos quedan 27
entre 74 y 27 entre 74 ya eso hay que
sumarle hay que sumarle 51 entre 74 51
entre 74 por y muy bien y entonces tras
tras distribuir este 74 finalmente
conseguimos nuestro número en una forma
bonita en la forma estándar de los
números complejos con su parte real y
con su parte imaginaria